okay
um good morning everybody and
i would like to thank the organizer
first for inviting me to speak
today about my research with chisholm
circulating as biomarkers to attack
cardiovascular disease um here are my
disclosure
which are known
and today we'll talk about some effects
of anthrocyclines
which are an important class of
chemotherapy drugs they are used against
several kind of cancers and they work by
different mechanisms of action
this mechanism results in two
principal outcomes which is
cygrochonibition and apoptosis induction
which are
very important against highly
proliferating cells
like cancer cells so obviously the main
effect
is to fight
cancer and so increase the life
expectancy of
subjects with cancer the main problem is
that there is also
a bad side to that which is
cardiotoxicity so
many subjects with cancer which are
treated they survive cancer but
they suffer from cardiac disease
uh what exactly is cardiotoxicity um
there is no
single definition but the main feature
is that there is a reduction in the
function of the heart which is usually
measured
as a left ventricular ejection fraction
so in the end what they suffer
the subject suffer is functional
impairment
there are different forms of
cardiotoxicity
one is less severe meaning that
when the subjects suffer from acute
cardiotoxicity they usually have no
later problems but the problem is when
they suffer from cardiotoxicity
uh within one year or later than one
year after the end
of the treatments in this case they can
have several in acute problems
um how is uh
anticycline induced cardiotoxicity um
detected uh well this is it is detected
by
echocardiography the subjects are
monitored
through their treatment by
echocardiography and when
cardiotoxicity is present they present
a dysfunction so this is
something which is happening after the
dysfunction onset
i am really sorry okay again
okay um how is
um cardiac toxicity detected the
detection of cardiotoxicity
is obtained by echocardiography uh
this is something which is due to the
monitoring of the subjects
uh during or after the antrocycline
treatment
and when there is a problem with
um of dysfunction and
cardio functionality there is
the detection of cardiotoxicity but this
is something which is
possible to know only when the
hydrotoxicity and dysfunction is present
of course there are some markers that
are used actually but which are not
optimal the best one is caldectoponing
cadectoponin is a protein which is
present in the heart
the whole heart and functional arter
when there is cardiac damage troponin is
released
into the blood so in this case
if the subject treated with dental
cyclins have no
presence of troponins or notopaining
increase
we know that they are okay they do not
require
cardiac monitoring and they have a low
risk of
problems uh the problem is when there is
a positive
increase of troponin in the blood so in
this case
we know that these subjects are at risk
of
um sorry cardiotoxicity
uh but the problem is that that we do
not know
when and how much there will be
an impact of on their life and
cardiac function so the predict value
is low so we thought about micrornas
which are small non-coding rnas
they are transcribed into the nucleus of
every
cell of our body there is a long
transcript
which is present in the nucleus then the
the transcript is processed and cut
and it goes to the cytoplasm when there
is another processing
and the the end product is a small
21 to 23 nucleotides a single strand
rna which is then bound to a protein
complex
called risk which is the active player
in the function of micrornas inside the
cells
but but we were speaking about
circulating micrornas
so in this case the micronase they go
outside the cell they can be found in
plasma and other
human fluids bound to proteins or inside
vesicles
they're very stable because they are
protected from nucleuses
and they have been proposed as
biomarkers of several diseases
so we decided to investigate and
research
whether they could be used as biomarkers
of
ultracycline induced cardiac damage and
that was the aim
of our research so to investigate their
role in
cardiotoxicity
and here is our experimental design we
collected samples from
88 breast cancer subjects
these subjects were evaluated for
cardiac function
before the treatment with either
doxorubicin or a pyruvatin which are two
anticyclines and we obtained also
blood samples then the subjects were
monitored and treated with doxorubicin
and again
we obtained the samples during
the treatment and after the treatment so
we have three time points
here which is the baseline before the
treatment t1 during the treatment and
one month after the treatment and the
follow-up
which is three to twelve months after
the last infusion of the oxalobasin
so the aim was the identification of
circulating markers
of cardiotoxicity unfortunately
for us not for the subjects
not cardiotoxicity was detectable so the
subject suffered
no problems of cardiac function
so we had to do some rearrangement
of our research research and we into the
identification of the equality micronese
as predictive markers
of cardiac damage
the experimental design is similar but
in this case
we decided to divide the cycles into
groups basing on the presence
or absence of an increase of troponin
levels
in their blood and of course they were
also divided
on the base of treatment either doctor
will be seen or a peruvian so we have
four groups and then i'm
showing you some methods uh
for each some sample a plasma sample
obtain it from
the subjects we did a rna extraction
uh followed by microneedle transcription
which
is in a universal transcription every
microneed is later transcribed at the
same time in the same
um in the same tube for each
sample followed by
an operating open array based screen
in this case this is a qrt pcr based
screening
we had an open array in which we spotted
more than 100 different micronese which
are
heart related micro microgrenades
are selected on the basis of the
literature and on our experience
uh on circulating micronase related to
cardiovascular disease
uh the screening was conducted at
baseline so before
any kind of treatment in the case of the
subject
uh on six samples from each of the four
groups uh then the results of the
screening were analyzed and we
identified
micronesia of interest which were
validated on all samples
of each group
and the principle results of this line
where on that we came up with three
microneeds which were upregulated
only in patients treated with lately
later treated with the doxorubicin so
microneed one two two
four nine nine and eight eight five five
b
so we had results only in the
doxorubicin europe
because unfortunately no epilepsy
associated microwaves were identified
uh we didn't give up and we went on
working on the dr rubicin group
of course the following step uh was to
look at
the behavior of this micronesia in the
different endpoints after baseline and
we didn't see any difference
in the expression of this micronese
a later time point so we focused on the
baseline which was our interest and
we posed a question whether we could be
able to identify
um those patients um with high risk
of cardiotoxicity so to separate based
on the expression of these three
micrornas
the patients with or without an increase
in troponin and we came up with a um
encouraging results as you can see by
clustering
analysis and rock cube analysis uh we
had a
good accuracy uh using the cluster of
micronase identified by
us to separate confidently
this this patient so we came up
with a possible algorithm for future
studies which
could be the proposal for future
clinical applications
in this case there are breast cancer
subjects with an indication
from for treatment with denturocyclines
there are different
anticyclines as i said before so the
clinician have to select
one particular androcycline and we
propose they do
a plasma microneed analysis
which indicates whether there is a
potential risk for these patients for
certain um selected ultracycline and in
the case of a potential
risk the clinicians could revisit
their options and select another kind of
drug
uh of course in the case of no indicated
potential
um cardiotoxicity risk indicated by the
micronese
the treatment crew continuous plan so
this is what we propose
to do in the future after our hopefully
successful investigations
but we don't um
we didn't limit our investigation only
to uh the the human
the humans we also tested an animal
models of dr rubicin this is a
quite um useful model
in which we took some mice we treated
the mice with doxorubicin for two weeks
and and then we collected plasma in this
case
because it was a study gain on
circulating macronutrients
and we collected plasma and investigated
cardiac function
um at the end of the treatment which is
um
after 14 days the t14 and then
also one week and one month later than
the end of the
treatment of demise so t21 and t42
and i don't know if it's
quite clear these are this is a picture
depicting
on the the function of the
three groups we identified so um we
identified three groups of mice
treated and untreated and some of the
mice
evidenced some real problems it is uh
the red box
and so there was a decrease in the
function of the heart
and so we again try to determine
whether we could uh see differences uh
on using unsupervised analysis so at
baseline the mice are all the same if we
analyze them on the basis of their
cardiac function
but then at t42 we see that the mice
are not all the same there is a group of
mice presenting
cardiac dysfunction which is separated
from
the other mice either untreated or
treated with oxyrubicin so there is a
differential response to the drug
and then we analyzed uh this mice
so we took the plasma from all the mices
and again we did total rna extraction
and uh open array analysis and and
to cut a long story short we
identified eight micrornas presenting
different regulation upon
treatment and the cardiac dysfunction
and so these are the results from the
three groups and
in particular we identified four
macronese which again we use to try to
to see whether they could identify a
demise presenting cardiac problems
between in the treated group
so again this is a presentation of the
3d clustering uh you can see that by
using
the expression of a restricted cluster
of micronesis we can separate
completely the mice treated redoxer will
be seen
uh when they are they are affected which
are the red
red dots so these are mice affected with
cardiac dysfunction and not affected
so treated with doxorubicin but not
affected
in their cardiac function we also try to
see whether this microorganism um
indicated
some problem and some separation in the
um these mice basing on their credit
function but we
didn't find anything which was
particularly useful
um of course in by
closing my presentation i have to say
some limitation of our
studies so known particularly as i said
none of the
subjects will be evaluated at any sign
of character toxicity
so this is a work for the future and
cardiac troponin was evaluated
using different methods because there
was a
multicenter study so we were not able to
correlate
uh troponin expression with microneed
expression
and of course another limitation is
limited number or micrornas
and also the animal models must be
refined this is a very
uh used quite useful animal models but
the mice
do not have cancer so it is not really
mimicking
um the the human situation 100
but we have future plans of course for
our research so
we would like to further evaluate uh
other subjects or human subjects to
identify
new micrornas which we would like to
analyze by next generation sequencing in
order to
look at many many microneed as many as
possible
and one thing that would be useful would
be an analysis in young
subjects suffering from cancer which
have a long expected
life so we would like to follow them in
time
but in conclusion we demonstrated that
circulating microneeds are indeed
good candidates as biomarkers to be
associated with cardiotoxicity and to
prevent hydrotoxicity with
possible future applications we
will go on with our translational
studies
okay in the end i would like to thank
all the people participating to
this project to this project uh in
particular the
monzino group with sonia matthias
veronica
really really a key person and
for the the recruitment of the subject
so magic
of course i have to also acknowledge the
funding agency
and i would like to thank everybody for
your attention thank you